underneath this heading I'd like you to
write the following following we know
how to solve simultaneous equations and
I'd like you to help me finish the
sentence we've learned yesterday we
reviewed quickly one way one method one
strategy for solving simultaneous
equations it involved doing what it
involved drawing right we had to graph
them and then what we were searching for
the solution of this simultaneous
equations was what what was it yeah
where the two where the two lines me
it's a point yeah that guy right there
okay so we know how to solve
simultaneous equations we would call
this method the graphical method because
you got a graph right so we know how to
do it graphically the solution is the
intersection point you don't need to
have that on your diagram you can just
write it as a separate sentence but
since I've got one I'm just going to
leave it alone there okay now this is
all well and good when number one your
equations are nice and convenient and
neat and number two when you've got like
a grid on there and it's easy to read
off I like where is that thing okay but
I can very easily come up with equations
that make this impossible for example
let's call this guy I don't know y
equals 2 let's make it 3/7 X plus 5 over
11 and what might this be I don't know
maybe 181 of
17 X minus 79 okay
now I just made up these numbers but
think about this for a moment right see
how these figures here are all really
messy awkward numbers right because
they're missing awkward numbers when
they meet they're going to meet at a
messy awkward number and even if you got
like very fine grid lines you're never
going to be able to accurately measure
just with your eyes where the
intersection point is so this graphical
method has this big learning hole which
is that it's inaccurate okay
so underneath this I want you to make a
little subheading which is the algebraic
method
okay so I said before that the graphical
method is lovely when you got nice this
nicely simple numbers but it's just kind
of a disaster it's just completely
inadequate if all we use if we have
these messy numbers here hi are you
looking for
thanks okay I will um I'll send them
thank you I think it's now oh wait no
I'm fine yeah which is later I don't
know why you're getting it now oh it is
sorry ah lunch already past you guys can
go might as well go through here doesn't
say it's pretty early in the lesson I
think it's fine no why if it's an
important meeting you don't wanna turn
up with chocolate in your mouth just
saying okay well you're talking about
okay sorry guys let's uh let's regain
our focus these numbers are not messy so
we could solve this graphically but I'm
gonna use these nice these numbers
because there's just be easier for our
brain at the moment okay how can we
solve this without ever going anywhere
near a graph here's how is a few
different ways the first thing we're
gonna do and I'd like you to do this
with me is we need someone to talk about
these equations separately because
they're not the same equation so I'm
gonna label them and I do it like so I
literally have a line going across to a
little one in a circle and lying on it
across the little two in a circle so
this is equation one equation two okay
now I can do a variety of things
to bring equation one into into contact
with each other to get them to talk to
each other a little bit right for
example see how the first equation says
y equals and then the second equation
also says y equals right what that means
is if this is equal Y and this is equal
to Y well doesn't it stand to reason
that these things should be equal to
each other are they're both equal to Y
yeah the way that we would call this is
we are going to equate 1 and 2 ok so you
can see I put these numbers in circles
because we don't do this very often that
way you know I'm talking about the
equation it's not just the number one in
the number two so if I quote one and two
I get X minus 1 and 2x plus 3 well this
is a simple equation just like any other
I've solved what could I do
someone to give me a suggestion of what
I could do to get toward a solution
just give me one step Yeah right
ok I'm gonna do something with the XS
but I'm not gonna move anything anywhere
what operation could I do that would
make it look like some X's moved yeah ok
I will all subtract an X from both sides
that means this one's gone so I just
leaves me with negative one and on the
right hand side that leaves me with a
single X plus 3 I'll keep going I want X
on its own so the operation that's left
to do is subtract 3 that leaves me with
this do you agree ok now look what we've
got here we have an x value okay from
what we know about solving things
algebraically
sorry graphically we usually get next
value by looking for it we're like oh I
think it's about there or wherever
happens to be but we don't just want an
x value if we want to know where that is
we also need a Y value you know whatever
whatever that happens to be okay so how
will I find that ok I'm going to take
this x value I might as well write it on
the left hand side and I'm going to
substitute it back into one of these
equations
which one now here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna ask this side of the room to
take this value here and substitute it
into equation 1 and then I'd like this
side of the room to substitute the same
value but into equation 2 instead okay
so wherever you see an X you're going to
put negative 4 instead can you go ahead
and do that for me anything okay hands
up who's already done the substitution
got an answer hands up straight heads up
straight okay think your hands down all
at once the answer is now whichever side
you were you got the same answer
didn't you now let's think about why
this is the case this is really
important put your pen down for a second
because you need to watch this bit we
all got the same answer here is why you
know how we're solving simultaneously
and what that means is the solution is
the intersection point what that means
is this point that we find it's not just
on this line or on this line it's on
both lines right that means it should
satisfy both equations that's so
important let me say it again okay the
point we're looking for the solution by
definition it's on both lines that's why
it's the intersection point okay if the
points on both lines then this value
satisfies both equations that makes
sense because these equations are in a
real sense they are these lines it's
just will not these particular lines
they are lines you can visualize them
okay in fact let's now do that quickly
can you please just draw me a rough
version don't worry don't even use your
ruler this time I just want to get a an
intuition draw a rough Cartesian plane
and let's think about what these lines
would look like X minus 1 and 2x plus 3x
minus 1 I think it'll look something
like that
right if that's one there okay 2x +3
what would that look like
1 2 3 there's the y-intercept
what is the to tell you it's gonna be a
bit steeper than the other one okay so
me something like this okay
now we're not solving this graphically
so it's not important for it to be
precise but all I want to confirm is hey
look at that intersection point that's
that's what the solution is does this
look like it matches reasonably with
that intersection point negative 4
negative 5 it looks good to me
it's in the right quadrant even the
scale is reasonably okay and I just did
it by freehand okay so graphically we
can confirm what we found algebraically
okay